[Música]
les voy a contar dos historias ambas muy
personales para mí y ambas marcaron un
hito muy importante en la forma en la
que yo empecé a ver la salud
siempre fue muy observadora pero sobre
todo muy curiosa
la primera historia los viernes era
tradición que mi abuelo venga a casa a
almorzar
semana tras semana empecé a notar que su
humor no era el mismo su sonrisa se
había esfumado y su tolerancia era cero
verlo así me generaba muchísimo malestar
ver a una persona que uno quiere pasarla
mal suele ser bastante desagradable
pensaba que a lo mejor haciéndolo
sonreír algo en él podía cambiar de
repente ese día o esa tarde
terquedad es mi segundo nombre y como
adolescente lo era aún más así que
empecé a repetir le sonrío y sonríe
y no parece hasta que a regañadientes
luego de un rato lo hizo ese día al
despedirme de él lo acompañé hasta el
carro y cuando se iba él le grite no te
olvides de sonreír
el viernes siguiente vino a casa ya
había impreso muchos stickers con
caritas felices me dio demasiada ternura
me dio uno para que yo no me olvide
sonreír y juntos pegamos uno de la parte
de atrás de su agenda que ha sido
siempre como su tercer brazo
unas semanas después fui a visitarlo a
su casa y encontré que había pegado los
mismos stickers en todos los espejos de
la casa y no solo en los espejos sino
también en otros lugares que él
consideraba estratégicos de esta forma
todos los que pasáramos por esos sitios
tendríamos que sonreír al paso
es increíble como una sonrisa puede
cambiarlo todo luego de eso en mis
momentos más difíciles y más oscuros ha
estado el para decirme sonríe y cuanto
molesta que te pidan que sonrías cuando
no le estás pasando bien pero cuánto
ayuda después de que lo haces
la segunda historia que les voy a contar
ya es en la carrera cuando llevamos el
curso de cirugía tenemos que hacer
guardias en la emergencia del hospital
imagínense el movimiento que hay en el
hospital que abarca la población del
conosur en la capital de nuestro país
yo estaba transitando por un momento
emocionalmente bastante difícil para mí
saber que iba a ir esa noche al hospital
a pasar la guardia me generaba demasiada
ansiedad
el sonido de la ambulancia cada vez que
llegaba la emergencia me generaba
desagrado y mientras todos mis amigos se
peleaban para ver quién suturada primero
yo solamente podía pensar en el dolor
ajeno' de verdad que lo intente
los días iban pasando con tranquilidad
hasta que viví la guardia más terrible e
icónica de mi vida
nunca voy a olvidar esa madrugada en la
que se encontraron las siguientes cuatro
personas en el tópico de cirugía del
hospital
el primer paciente adulto mayor de 78
años viene a la emergencia por una
herida por arma de fuego en la pierna
derecha
dice que estaba en su casa donde vive
solo porque su familia no lo visita hace
mucho tiempo estaba tranquilo cuando de
pronto empezó a escuchar gritos que
provenían de la casa del costado sabía
que era la vecina no es la primera vez
que esto sucede y cuando ella grita su
marido grita más fuerte este día fue
distinto así que decidió salir y
enfrentar al agresor el resto de la
historia es evidente
está sentado solo lo veo muy vulnerable
no tiene familiares que abogan por él en
este momento
sostiene en una mano fuertemente un
pañuelo con sangre para compensar el
dolor y en la otra mano veo que tiene un
papel con un teléfono que debe ser de
algún familiar me doy cuenta que tiene
muy pocas monedas y estoy segura que no
van a alcanzar para poder pagar los
medicamentos
yo no podía haber un adulto mayor con
una herida por arma de fuego solo veía a
un anciano
vulnerable en estado de abandono y
viviendo al costado de una familia donde
la violencia doméstica era pan del día a
día
segundo paciente adulto de
aproximadamente 40 años llega en estado
etílico al hospital quejándose de dolor
abdominal en la parte inferior derecha
en los momentos en los que no gritaba de
dolor
aprovechada para voltear y hacer chistes
de índole sexual al personal femenino de
turno me siento demasiado incómoda
cada vez que nos piden que lo examinemos
y levantamos la sábana el olor a alcohol
y a sudor me genera demasiadas náuseas
yo no podía haber una apendicitis
yo veía una persona de sexo masculino
machista que de acuerdo a su historia
tenía evidentes problemas de alcoholismo
le habrían hecho en algún momento un
diagnóstico habría ya ha recibido algún
tratamiento mi mayor pregunta era habría
hecho daño a alguien a una mujer a un
niño en la niña o alguna persona
vulnerable en algún momento de su vida
tercera paciente mujer de
aproximadamente 23 años acude a la
emergencia con una herida en el mentón
nos cuenta que ha estado tomando con sus
amigos
que es su pareja que ya le ha pegado
anteriormente le ha sido infiel de nuevo
mientras chilla de dolor nos va
expresando también todos sus traumas de
vida abuso sexual en la infancia
invalidación por parte de la madre
intente ese suicidio en el pasado
violencia por parte de la pareja y ganas
de morir en el presente no puedo dejar
de mirar el mentón abierto como una
fruta reventada
de manera constante estira los brazos
trata de buscarnos para agarrarnos
pero nos alejamos de las manos
ensangrentadas en el fondo lo único que
está buscando es contención de alguno de
nosotros
los tatuajes que tiene a lo largo del
cuerpo nos van contando parte de su
historia
yo no podía ver un mentón para suturar
por planos ustedes ya se imaginarán lo
único que podía ver yo
cuarta paciente puede esperar algunas
semanas viene al hospital cargando a su
bebé con dificultad para andar tenía la
herida de la cesárea abierta e infectada
tiene muchas dificultades para
comunicarse con nosotros nos damos
cuenta que es sordomuda ha venido sola
así que tenemos que turnarnos para poder
cargar al bebé mientras otros la van
curando
en ese momento me doy cuenta que
todo lo que veo está cada vez más
borroso siento la nuca caliente cada vez
siento menos los pies
tengo un sonido agudo que me está
perturbando y de pronto una amiga me
dice ya él parece es un papel
ese día después de la guardia lo único
en lo que podía pensar era en que el
problema físico de esas cuatro personas
que se encontraron en el tópico esa
noche ya estaba resuelto pero la salud
mental de ellos seguía en riesgo
quién iba a velar por ellos llegando a
casa quién iba a encargarse de que su
estado de ánimo se estable de que sus
sonrisas no desaparezcan quién se iba a
encargar de pegar los stickers en los
espejos de esas personas
sería alguno de ellos es una persona en
33.000 que tiene acceso a una cita con
un psiquiatra porque si sólo tenemos
1.196 psiquiatras en nuestro perú mi
nombre es ya él valdés querol soy mamá
de 2 soy médica cirujana general con
especialidad en psiquiatría soy
terapeuta dialéctica conductual sexóloga
clínica y sobre todo activista en salud
mental
soy lo que ya mencioné pero sobre todo
esto soy un ser humano con emociones
como todos los demás
estoy convencida de que el concepto de
salud debe continuar siendo desmembrado
y no me voy a cansar de repetirles las
veces que sean necesarias que la salud
mental es una parte importante de ésta
siento la necesidad de repetirles una y
otra vez y de visibilizar como parte de
mi misión de vida que los problemas de
salud mental existen y estoy dispuesta a
hacer lo que sea necesario para lograrlo
y si soy una de las mil 196 psiquiatras
en un país de casi 33 millones de
habitantes un país cuya coyuntura
política no da tregua y un país que está
entre los más afectados por la pandemia
del coi 19
hasta antes de la pandemia la
prevalencia de trastornos de salud
mental en el perú era de 33.7 por ciento
y ocho de cada diez peruanos que
necesitaban la atención no la recibían
en un estudio publicado recientemente
por el instituto nacional de salud
mental indican que tanto los problemas
de salud mentales como la violencia en
niños y adolescentes se ha incrementado
en un 50% durante la pandemia
podríamos decir que el suicidio es la
etapa final o más crítica del
sufrimiento emocional
es para muchos el último paso o la
salida ante la desesperanza ante el
miedo a no mejorar o ante la ausencia de
alternativas de solución
la última información que tenemos en
relación al suicidio es aquella
publicada por la organización mundial de
la salud cuya data es del 2019
indica que al año 800 mil personas se
quitaron la vida estamos hablando de una
persona cada 40 segundos
para ser un poco más gráficos pueden
imaginarse qué es lo que puede durar una
charla de té de c's hay 27 personas que
se quitan la vida
y por cada persona que se suicidó hubo
entre 20 y 30 que lo intentaron y no lo
lograron
entre los 15 y 29 años el suicidio es la
tercera causa de muerte en mujeres y la
cuarta causa de muerte en varones luego
de accidentes de tránsito tuberculosis y
violencia interpersonal
pueden imaginarse las cifras espantosas
que vamos a ver cuando salga el informe
de la ms con la información recolectada
en los años 2020 y 2021 estando en plena
pandemia
el encierro la pérdida de trabajo la
ausencia de contacto físico la tristeza
y el miedo ha sido lo que más hemos
vivido y consumido en estos últimos dos
años y estoy segura que esto solo va a
hacer que las cifras sean aún más
alarmantes
hay una pandemia que no estamos viendo y
esa pandemia es la de la salud mental
se acuerdan de esa guardia de esa
terrible e icónica guardia que viví les
cuento me terminé desmayando
luego de eso mis papás no tomaron mucho
tiempo en mandarme al psicólogo con el
psicólogo llegó la derivación al
psiquiatra me diagnosticaron de
depresión trauma y una fobia en la que
tuve que trabajar muchísimo para poder
terminar la carrera
tengo la suerte de que he crecido en una
familia en la que la salud mental es tan
importante como la salud física y donde
un cuerpo sano es igual de importante
que una mente sana pero lo que yo llamo
suerte no debería de ser llamado suerte
la salud mental es un derecho y el
acceso a ella debería ser universal e
igualitario para todos y todas
como seres humanos tenemos la
responsabilidad de construir una
sociedad donde la salud sea evaluada y
tomada en cuenta de forma integral y
donde nosotros y las generaciones
siguientes podamos expresar nuestro
malestar emocional de la misma forma en
la que manifestamos nuestros malestares
físicos
son ustedes los que van a tener que
pegar los stickers de la gente que
quieren cuando no se sientan bien son
ustedes los que van a tener que estar
alertas cuando la sonrisa de esas
personas se esfume y son ustedes los que
a partir de hoy no pueden olvidar lo
siguiente
la salud mental es salud